you know you walk in this house and the
first thing I see and I noticed is the
pictures of you and your wife yes how
you doing
[Music]
in a new experience that you have you
don't know how you're doing because
you've never experienced it
I have a lot of people
[Music]
depend on me
[Music]
all my supervisors said talk
it's time to man up
so I'm trying to man up
[Music]
but we're talking about not just a wife
or a partner with someone who was your
soulmate and also was a driving force
and all this you guys built something
that is an American original thank you
but you built it together yes how
where are you now when you you know when
they say let's go shoot and you're
looking for that partner well you know
for two three years she knew this might
happen so she would say
[Music]
who's gonna sit next to you
and I said no one
Big Daddy you better not let another
girl take my place I said I won't stoop
so I we I needed therapy in the therapy
she used when she was sick was to hunt
her therapy you know was hunting bounty
hunting catching a bad guy fixing him so
I thought you know what that I need to
do something because a phone calls and
this and that and you're just like wow
my god
everywhere you go daughter condolences
and I like that it's okay but did that
remind you you know I've went to people
that have lost a loved one and I'm like
God if I say you know I'm sorry lost
your daughter by the way brah I'm sorry
you know and then I had lost a daughter
and when people say that you're like
boom thank you but then you think of it
you know so it's hard so I needed the
therapy to bounty hunt so we're using a
lot of new technology and one of those
things is a drone of course we're all
using it right right yeah so the guy
yesterday as soon as we pulled up big
bun number one most wanted bolted took
off tried it and we kind of lost him he
got a jump on us right in his daylight
thank you God and as we were chasing in
one of the girls that were there my
bondsman friend's wife said dog we've
lost e and the boys were all this way
and my team was that way and I was this
way and I said
now I need an angel' etic drone and
you're up there don't you let him get
away Bethy and of course as the story
goes within minutes I heard him said
you'd leave him yell I I've got him I
broke my leg and I thought and I told
the girl her name is Shari that was all
we lost I said don't worry
we got somebody watching now that really
happened really happened because we he's
his brother who came to the hospital
later with him said ah he's gone he's
been here 22 years I don't know how you
guys found him Leland said all the
sudden he was the bear Leo said it's not
a spooky kind of kid and so he's like
dad something was leading me so you know
it's even though physically she's not
there unless I'm a nut then mentally and
you know spiritually she's there she's
really there watching and helping and
you know there's limits I'm sure in a
sense she is right here with us now is
it yeah I hope so
yeah yeah and then what's in that pink
box well I've never done ashes of my
life
and that's what she wanted and then she
wants me to do it putting the same thing
just put on the fireplace or something
so yeah this is the most morbid stuff
dry hole it's like it's like morbid
right when I was a little boy all the
Christians you can't get burned because
then you won't rise from the grave of
Jesus and then I said honey you know
what about that she goes it's from ashes
to ashes and dust to dust
okay so I wanted to put him in the car
seat build a bit and I want to take a
Whitney but it's that's like morbid you
know like like it you got to really
watch it these are the times where
people go over the edge and you really
got to watch how you do the other day
man if he goes dog you know I love you
I'm sorry I lost my wife six months ago
and I hugged him and I felt a connection
like boom boom right instantly
Brotherhood right so when you go through
something in somebody else and you know
there's something there so that's why
I'm not not that's why I'm going through
it but I used that thing that's bad to
help me help others for her final wishes
what if you want you to do with those
ashes
well she said scatter some leave some on
the fireplace of course when I go to
heaven she wants me in the box with her
and then I looked at and thought I'm not
gonna throw you like away I just throw
you away it start over and I can't do
that so right now I'd like him it can't
be more of it I don't you know I haven't
gotten past the place where I'm still
putting a pillow where she was and
covering it up like the jailhouse escape
hmm right I mean it and then I wake up
will like see her and it doesn't
register as any to her I'm still there
so it's really a morbid thing it's like
freaky as heck and there's chips in
their bra
I'm like what is these teeth they're
like well oh my god
yeah right oh my god right so it's a new
thing that because of Bethy I'm trying
to get through so tonight you you you
make a thing of it baby yeah yeah
because you I wake up to always touch
her especially when she was sick I had
to wake her up a few times she almost
quit breathing no I couldn't hear it no
more
and it's she's late I'm like I am you're
not dying right like that I will not let
you die
no way so I'm so used to that then I
don't sleep solid anymore because you
she'll die and she'd wake up go I'm
still alive baby and I said don't do
this you're gonna be okay but you every
day I wake up big that I'm still alive I
said of course you will be Constance I
can let you die like that I'm with you
don't we're not gonna let you die that
won't happen
oh sorry but nothing prepares you for
that the final moment does it well no I
mean it's like no you can't be okay
here's how it's gonna happen and here's
how it's gonna be but you see it all the
time you see it right you see it so
Google what do I do and I look at
pictures of us right mm-hmm and you know
people are now sending me pictures of
her with angel wings beautiful fitness
it's really beautiful and you know
there's my baby and then you see it
they're mighty like you know man I gotta
get this out of my mind you know because
you that's not what you're supposed to
see but you can know better
well it again psychologists say and
psychiatrists I'm sorry say time the
Bible says it to heals will heals wounds
time is it you know
the time is it but I'm getting older now
okay so I maybe not have a lot of that
time and about a year ago the Lord said
to me how do you want to go you hit that
age where you can decide what is that
way faster slow you decide
and I was like hole all day the thought
could kind of my mind I got an answer
and I go can I have a reprieve a timeout
can I get back to you later about this
sure he laughed I felt giggling and
after I seen how her she went slow
I said lord I figured it out I want to
go fast but you gotta let someone at
least read Genesis wanted one to be all
my staff has been advised if something
happens I want to hear Genesis 1 and
what so that I know that means to say
Lord forgive me for calling I mother or
you never know how I'm gonna go cuz i go
in i go in hard
ok smokin now we're on fire cuz i got a
whole new look on life I don't I always
watched how I did I've arrested eight
thousand men and women in a 41 year span
and I go in crazy cuz you got to are you
ready to go because you want to join
them well of course yeah I'm ready
you know yeah oh yeah I said you beat me
to this uh yellow there the other day
they got 31 million hits on a website 31
million Marty singing right 30 cents a
continent the guy called me said she
just beat Michael Jackson's record I go
no way I knew Michael Jackson I'm like
no way I said I walked outside said
alright you got me
I didn't stop if I shot the president
above Iraq because he was sent in nukes
I wouldn't get this she was very shallow
though right that doesn't that say but
yeah everybody hears bad
Big Daddy they love you they hate me
because oh yeah
she was so strong how many been people
do you expect to be here
Oh memorial service this service I have
no idea
I know snoop called me this morning said
I'm bringing a bodyguard I know what the
help really don't need them I got mine
too so I'm bringing mine I said alright
so I don't know you know Wow how
emotional will that service be well I've
got a man up okay so I don't know I mean
you've used don't what do you mean by me
you keep saying man well you just listen
is there a such thing as man and
in a situation like that you're asking
me that yes and you know there is you I
am a crybaby
I am I blame it on my heritage mm-hmm I
kill cry talking about crying is getting
back to work a way to move forward and
will someone like Bonnie or we have
somebody else step up into that place
they'll never be another bet there ain't
a girl built like another bet I see that
box but I also see the pictures of that
right now where does that where do you
keep the box I put it next to the bed
cause like it sounds gonna take it yes
tea on the belly and see build it in and
I thought that's too weird you know
don't be again man up watch it so I
leave it next to the bed right there and
I think that might be where it's gonna
be forever
how much Beth final days in her battle
will you show on the show and how hard
would it be to watch and relive that
I've already looked at some of them okay
and I see her and I hear and I freaking
start bawling cuz it happened I just
instantly start crying
because that did happen and she said it
and she prophesied it and done it out of
that right so I I think it's also
therapeutic that you have those you know
if you lose a loved one then you have
the little pictures you'd look at but I
have her live a bad show so I us I have
all the bonus shows we've been on TV 15
years and move that last day like I
think the last day was that morning one
before she couldn't breathe all of a
sudden she wasn't choked you guys doing
wasn't know the truth so that day we
talked a lot and I was not going to let
her die no one knows this right now the
last few moments
she said come in here right now on the
bathroom
I went and she said to look at me I said
yeah beautiful baby
look at me wait chattering I did
I always saw Beth and she said please
let me go
[Music]
and I didn't even make a decision before
I could say all right
she couldn't breathe all of a sudden aw
I can't breathe
and call ambulance and all that right
but we every day she talked about as if
she was not there mm-hmm
here's what to do with this here's what
to do with that you know don't keep
running your mouth and that when they
ask you a specific question just answer
that don't go into your dog isms
prepared you're never ever prepared it
can't you can't prepare there's no way
and come right on you the toothbrush
still right now is in the freaking jar
there was nothing I did not know this
was going to happen that day at all no
you know okay we hear stories of how
it's gonna happen but that comes way
down the road you were like she's gonna
make it oh yeah we did a lot of CBD and
all that to get managed her pain made
her eat and the doctor said to my face
if she wouldn't be doing it she'd of
went a long time ago so she says yeah I
can't I can't breathe and what do you do
I help put her arms up above her head
and then she I saw her die in my arms
she was so tidy she fell back and I
grabbed her hair and I pulled it up and
I just took one breath and breathed as
hard as I could and as I was blowing I
was thinking in my mind this is not how
to do it right you got a layer down one
two that you got you know I know what to
do all of a sudden she went and she
sucked back and I'm like oh my god and
then I carried her to the bed and called
911 baby and they finally got there we
rode the ambulance and you know she went
in and they put the thing down through
the cancer
you know they said it won't we can't do
it targets not going in Akane so she
dies you die doc got it yes sir
now you get that through there like an
arrow through a steer you got it
they went in you could hear it I see it
every day I see it all the time
how's everybody else doing how's Bonnie
here the grandkids how's everybody doing
they're all compared to what I stink I
would have done very good they're doing
a good job
by the way she had one of the funniest
quotes I've ever heard she said I was a
good girlfriend through three wives and
then she great said two wives and a
girlfriend
yeah but she was just she held nothing
there was no filter in that walk well I
was married to wanted one for four years
in one for one year and she kept saying
why I'm waited in line and I'm like and
what a mistake I mean not because we got
you know I'm a baby out of one of them I
did but it's still my baby I still with
me so yeah she a lot of years brought a
lot of years and I lost 17 pounds in
about two weeks and yesterday they
better not show this on my show the guy
was getting crazy finally got him put a
belt around the cuff start to walk had
him come in 265 and lean back and flip
me like a pancake I told you Vera show
it right now make a deal and of course
they won't we'll try not to know so I
need some more what you know I need to
bulk up again but I can't even I can't
eat I get to buy some full you know
there's a lot of so I got to force feed
myself like I force-fed Irv keep going
to keep going yep well and I'm not
suicidal please like God know people
want to say that oh now I'm dog suicide
suicide oh yeah I would never do that so
you're saying if you have to go you're
ready yes absolutely
Beth was never ready there's five or
seven things right
denial making a deal blaming someone and
the doctor told me and the final one is
acceptance
[Music]
I said well brah that there's property
of dog she's never gonna get to
acceptance she never did
she never accepted it she wasn't ready
nope
and she told me times we read that out
loud okay now here's acceptance she goes
our way we're not getting there she said
all right baby I got you see now you're
talking positive with me it ain't your I
got can't force the AIDS cat lung cancer
throat cancer it ain't your cancer it is
cancers trying to attack you it is I
have the symptoms and the likeness of it
you don't claim it you don't want it I'm
gonna die you don't say that Beth you
say this you said I'm not sure well this
is all we got to guide us is this book
that says that tongue is between life
and death it's that powerful watch what
you say watch what you confess all these
rich guys that write all these books and
have all these secrets about stuff
success it's the tongue bottom line
whether it's evil or good that tongue
both that is really I've seen it now
live long enough the Bible talks about
knowledge and wisdom comes at this age
last year got it
so cuz you've been there done that
you're gettin through it it's not
because your eye Mucka Mucka and no one
else is everybody gets like that who do
you figure man
[Music]